a quiet place is packed with many tents
nerves shredding moments however one
special scene between John Krasinski and
Emily Blunt is loaded with much more
meaning than you might realize
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm taking a deep dive into a
quiet place to explain the secret story
behind the movies earbud scene and why
director John Krasinski insisted it had
to be in the movie spoilers ahead if you
haven't seen the film yet in the earbud
scene emily Blunt's evelyn and her
husband lee take a moment for a slow
dance together and in doing so briefly
tune out the horror of their everyday
life hiding from the sound sensitive
aliens that threaten them it's a very
tender moment and as a two parents weigh
together
Evelyn takes out one of her ear birds
and shares a song she's listening to
with Lee the song is Harvest Moon by
Neil Young and it's the only song that
plays in the movie the curious thing
about this song choice is that it's a
very expensive song to license and given
the film's tight budget it wasn't
something the production could really
afford
however for kasinski who wrote this
scene as part of his rewrite of the
original script it was vital to have
this specific song in the movie
according to producer Andrew form
Krasinski would not stop until he got
that song so why was it so important for
kasinski to play this expensive song in
his relatively low-budget movie well
first of all it's a very personal track
for Kaczynski and his real-life wife
Emily Blunt as two of their close
friends got married to the song in fact
on the first take the couple shot of
that intimate scene
Krasinski looked up and saw not only he
and Blunt were crying at the exact same
time but their crew were also welling up
and beyond that personal connection
there are also multiple levels of
meaning to the song itself Neil Young
who wrote and performed Harvest Moon has
said that it's about this feeling this
ability to survive and continue and grow
and get higher than you were before you
can be more alive which as I explained
in my quiet place ending video is a key
theme in the movie how a family not only
survives an alien invasion but aims to
thrive and grow in spite of it
over the years since its released though
some have interpreted the song was more
bittersweet being about the love that in
Jaws even when a couple are no longer
together the line when we were lovers I
loved you with all my heart could hint
at two people who were separated and so
the song could foreshadow the
heartbreaking events later in the movie
when lee sacrifices himself to save his
family with the lyrics implying that Lee
and Evelyn will still remain connected
in spirit even though he's gone on top
of that a harvest moon as a full moon
that occurs closest to the autumn
equinox and usually coincides with the
September or October full moon and as we
see on the family's calendar the due
date for the Abbott's new baby is the
day before the October full moon
traditionally the Harvest Moon also had
special meaning for rural communities
like in a quiet place because it meant
there was plenty of moonlight even after
sunset which helped win harvesting crops
at that time of year and it fits in with
the idea of the seasons of life again
foreshadowing Halley's life will be
coming to an end
all in all the song is a bittersweet and
tender moment for the couple as they
savor some brief time together and
anticipate the arrival of their new baby
it's also an instant of respite for the
audience watching the movie as the
silence fades out and we can relax with
a gentle song before the full horror of
their fate kicks in and adding another
layer of meaning to the song is the fact
that Neil Young made his Harvest Moon
album at a time when he was suffering
from tinnitus and couldn't listen to any
loud noises Young had damaged his
hearing while working on an earlier
album and concert tour which makes a
song even more appropriate for a quiet
place now just for a bit of fun
fans of John Krasinski in the office may
also link the quiet place earbuds scene
with the time that Jim shared his
earbuds with Pam in a similarly romantic
moment in season two of the popular show
I don't know whether christiansí had
that sweet Jim and Pam moment in mind
when he wrote this scene in a quiet
place but either way it's a nice
callback for fans of the show so did you
spot any other hidden meanings in a
quiet place and what do you think about
the earbud scene leave me a comment with
your thoughts below and you can also
tweet me to discover more about a quiet
place tapleft to check out my full
ending and creatures explained video and
tap right for my breakdown of the movies
deleted scenes if you enjoyed this hit
the like button and subscribe for more
of my videos thanks for watching and see
you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers